what's up guys today we are talking 3D
Legos and how fun it is to build your
own in Bricklink Studio push them to the
max in your favorite 3D programs like
Cinema 4D or blender and even how to
composite them into live action footage
because over the last month I have been
working on this Lego Passion project it
combines my long time love for building
Legos 3D and VFX work and visual
storytelling and I cannot wait to show
you guys the final film when it drops
later this summer but in this video I'm
excited to walk you guys through this
unique 3D to 2D workflow and see how you
use all the tips and tricks we're going
to cover in your own projects so it all
started with this book the Lego engineer
by Jeff Friesen I was immediately drawn
to these beautifully designed Studio lit
micro scale Lego builds of Real World
objects not just one of these perfect
Little Creations in my life and thought
how cool would it be to composite these
3D micro scale Lego builds into live
action footage and what's a cooler Place
To Shoot footage in than Japan so my
wife and I embarked on a road trip from
the hustle and bustle of Tokyo to the
Serene gifu Countryside and Beyond to
Kyoto the city of shrines and temples
and along the way I made a habit of
filming whatever piqued my interest with
this Lego Concept in the back of my mind
and I wanted to be as open to wherever
the idea took me regardless of whether I
thought it could work for the so-called
edit or not and I made it a goal of
making this the exploration phase of the
project I didn't need to judge the work
yet I just told myself look have fun
with this and shoot let the future mean
take care of what's good or what's bad
and after two weeks of travel I compiled
about 50 or so solid shots and I was
more than excited to start the VFX
process on so let me take you guys
through a couple of my favorite shots
starting with the Lego building process
pretty quickly I realized how difficult
it was to make these micro scale Lego
masterpieces just based on the
references I pulled alone it's easy to
see that these are masterfully crafted
works of art if I want to get this short
film done this year I need to team up
with someone who knows every single
piece I need someone who knows all the
tricks inside and out I need a Lego
building Master
who
and where
man I I need help that's why I'm here
for Paul leffert has been building Legos
for decades now and his micro skill
architecture builds are a testament to
that he's surrounded by all the physical
pieces in his office so we can
brainstorm complicated ideas and he's
proficient in a cad style Lego software
called Bricklink Studio it's clear to me
that Paul is the man for the job so
let's get building using Bricklink
Studio it's free you can download it
it's in the description Paul's gonna
build out the giant Shinto Shrine that's
hanging above the center of the Ring
inside Tokyo's famous Sumo Hall I tried
to build this out myself and man it is
harder than it looks guys Paul's process
is pretty cool at a certain point if he
gets stuck in Bricklink Studio he'll
turn to the physical pieces to
troubleshoot and brainstorm then back to
Studio where he can finish things out
now it's just as easy as exporting a
colada file from Bricklink Studio
converting that file to an fbx using
this ancient Autodesk converter don't
worry it's free and link below that way
way we can bring it in a Cinema 4D
blender unreal whatever so we can move
on to the next step getting it lit
getting it textured and getting it
aligned to the live action shot but
first let's take a couple seconds to
admire Paul's beautiful handiwork Paul
crushed this Sumo Hall Shrine it turned
out so nice not to mention all these
other genius builds for other shots in
this short film coming out soon but in
the meantime if you guys want to see
exactly how Paul built these custom
Legos he's got a video on his channel
covering the entire process and he even
made custom instructions so you guys can
build those Legos yourself if you want I
got the video linked below go show ball
some love especially if you're a Lego
fan because he's got you covered with
all the awesome videos on his channel so
let's light texture and align our model
to our footage I'll use Cinema 4D but
you guys can just as easily use blender
since it's free of course or any other
3D software to accomplish the same steps
first let's match our 3D camera to the
original shot so that our Lego model
sits correctly in the footage luckily
since all of these shots are simple
nodal pans versus free moves I need to
3D track these shots I got tutorials and
all that stuff if you need it but for us
I'll simply make a camera right click
and add a camera calibration tag where
we can add our reference image select
the various axes in our reference frame
set a center point and Bam aligned if
you're in blender I know F spy does the
same exact thing so check out F spy also
got that link below for you if you need
it now that our camera is aligned and
matched let's match our 3D lighting to
the lighting in our footage but first I
got to give Aces some love for sponsor
in this video for the traveling artist
having a solid mobile workstation is
almost as important as the at-home
desktop if you're in the market for a
laptop hear me out because you can
easily knock out projects like this on
their new Pro Art Studio book 16 OLED
laptop it's equipped with a gorgeous
color accurate 16 inch 3.2 K OLED
touchscreen display and its color
accuracy is graded at Delta e less than
one which means its color accuracy is
beyond what the human eye can even
perceive the 120 hertz true black
display is perfect for trading on the go
3D art while simultaneously giving you
the best gaming and movie watching
experience it comes loaded with a 24
core Intel processor with clock speeds
up to 5.6 gigahertz making 3D tasks like
simulation a heck of a lot faster and up
to an Nvidia RTX 4070 GPU it ships with
32 gigabytes of upgradable RAM up to 64
as well as a one terabyte SSD drive also
upgradable to 8 terabytes for quick file
transfer and storage for all your
applications it comes loaded with full i
o support so two really cool features I
dig on the pro art laptop is this
touchpad is actually stylus compatible
for writing or drawing and the Asus dial
which lets you control things like
brightness and volume by default but by
using the new and improved Pro art
Creator Hub you can configure the dial
to adjust brush size saturation layer
opacity and more for the longest time I
have needed a laptop to support my
creativity on the go and after using the
Asus Pro art laptops I am happy to say a
legit vouch for these things they can do
everything from render complex 3D scenes
in your 3D programs of choice to editing
hi-res footage or compositing in After
Effects not to mention they're perfect
for mobile gaming and Lan parties too so
click that link in the description down
below to learn more about the Asus Pro
Art Studio book and lastly I just want
to say thank you to all the artists who
participated in the Asus Pro artist
Awards 2023 the contest ends today and I
cannot wait to take a look at all of
your animations now let's get back to
the art now there's a handful of little
tips and tricks that I use to match the
light as it's such an important step I
almost always start with a high dynamic
range image hdris are made by stitching
together a series of bracketed images
ultimately creating a 360 degree sphere
of your custom environment and we'll use
this image to light our 3D scene ideally
I would have captured a custom hdri for
every shot I filmed but I did not have
time while on vacation so here's what
I'll do instead go to hdri Haven and
grab an hdri that resembles your scene
the closest we'll use one of these
images to get our lighting to the 85
Mark now to light our scene with this
image I'll drop it into an HDR
environment object and hit render
success
but we ain't done yet because let's use
the path Tracer to get those realistic
light bounces turn our render samples
down so we don't start a forest fire
decrease the GI clamp to avoid unwanted
artifacts on our Reflections and make
our background transparent to have our
background image visible in the renderer
and the viewport you can create a
background object via the calibration
tag bam we got lights we we got a camera
but let's take this lighting to the next
level first let's add an octane camera
tag to our camera and enable the camera
imager here we can dial in the exposure
gamma saturation all that good stuff to
better match our render to our
background plate the closer we can match
this here in post the easier our
compositing job in After Effects will be
you can also enable some post glow and
of course let's orbit our hdri until we
feel it best matches the lighting in our
footage and here's where the real spice
comes in remember how I said the hdri is
going to get us 85 percent of the way
there we'll buckle up for the other 15.
since hdri's consider every light
captured in the scene the same distance
away they're just infinitely far away
we're going to recreate some of these
lights in 3D to really spice up our
scene so I'll radially clone a couple
rings of scaled down area lights drop
the intensity to a reasonable amount and
take a look at this difference it really
makes the material shine and speaking of
materials let's bring our materials to
the next level with some surface
imperfections first I will will convert
our c4d materials to Octane materials if
you're using redshift you convert them
to redshift materials now I can select
all these materials and make batch edits
first I'll take the roughness down to a
really low value because I want my Lego
pieces to have that nice Sheen another
thing I want to do is bevel these edges
and I can actually do that with a round
edges node in these octane materials
that way the brakes don't look as
clinical I'll just dial in a low value
and make sure they're set to Accurate
next I'll open the node editor and drop
in a scratch texture from my brand new
Surface imperfections volume 2-pack
which I got at 50 off for you guys this
week only it's 12 16 bit 4K seamless
non-GMO textures at 50 off this week
only go grab some but yeah this totally
does the job it makes it look like that
one time you tried to pry your pieces
apart with a fork or something next I'll
drop a smudge texture from my volume one
pack into the roughness channel to get
that greasy child hand all over the
pieces kind of look now be sure to use a
transform node on both of these images
to control how much they tile and a
projection node set to box to tile the
images accurately a multiply node out to
a float texture will help you tone down
the scratches and an octane gradient
will help you dial in the amount of
smudging feel free to add a dirt node up
in the color channel for a bit of
ambient occlusion if the situation calls
you can up the index if you want these
bad boys to be a bit shinier depending
on your scene and look as well finally I
want to give the pieces a slight Touch
of positional inconsistency to them they
really help sell the hand-built look for
this I'll simply add a planar field with
the slightest touch of positional and
rotational input making sure to set the
deformation mode to object and with a
custom light setup spice lights the
double down on the ones in our footage
surface imperfections and some random
positioning on the bricks to make them
feel hand built it's time to render this
out and stick it in our footage using
After Effects lucky for us we only gotta
render one frame because it's not
animated or part of a 3D track sequence
so imma just hit file save image where
you can export whatever file type you
want and if you want to split this image
up into specific render layers you can
set that up by making sure octane is
selected as the renderer and under aov
groups you can add whatever pass you
want say post processing for example if
you set up that bloom earlier choose a
destination and let's get comping in
After Effects calling all 3D artists if
you
challenges and have been waiting for the
right opportunity to join the next one
now is the time this August let's learn
and grow together through the new summer
3D challenge we got a new super fun
prompt for you guys so be sure to
subscribe to this channel so you don't
miss out on the big reveal on July 29th
so the compositing stage is truly my
favorite part of this whole process
because all of our setup all of our hard
work comes together here so we'll drag
our render in and the first thing we'll
do is stick it to our footage this
process is called tracking camera
tracking or match moving we'll be 2D
tracking our footage with mocha today
which comes built into After Effects so
I'll skip to the middle of our footage
where we can see everything I'll grab
our handy pen tool and draw a mask
around the area we want to track I'll
first track forward then backward I do
this because it makes for a more
accurate track a lot of the times it's
situational yes but like if you throw a
ball from half court you're more likely
to score than if you'd thrown it from
the other side of the Court you know I
mean I don't know if that works once
complete just close and save make a null
object to hold our tracking data and
under the mocha effect we'll click
create track data to ensure our layer is
toggled we'll select transform from the
drop down and our null object to apply
the data to and Bam pick with the render
to the null and we are locked in just
don't forget to toggle the motion blur
so since I'm actually colorblind color
matching can be difficult for me alright
so let me show you how I'm doing it give
your Lego a levels adjustment select the
red Channel and set the composition
color channel to red as well so by
removing color as a factor we're
essentially value matching our elements
now which ideally offers us a more
objective way to composite so when we
switch back to color our element should
in theory be much closer than it was
before let's zoom in and you'll notice
our render is a bit more crisp than the
footage that's where a little fast blur
and grain comes in keep it subtle though
because it doesn't take much to match
the degradation of your footage but for
some shots like this this one that I
filmed on my iPhone 10 the quality loss
is a bit more noticeable so I'm just
stacking a few iterations of fast blur
and some unsharp masks to get that
crunchy iPhone look and topping it off
with some grain alright so it is time we
talked about rotoscoping specifically
how to do it quickly because most of you
guys hate it don't have time for it and
are looking for any excuse to not be
doing it but what if the shot calls for
it like this one these trees got to be
scoped out you know normally you would
use the Roto brush and go frame by frame
making adjustments along the way which
honestly isn't the worst option you
could export it out to runwayml and
generate a mat to bring back into after
effects or Fusion also not a bad method
but I want to show you guys one more and
it's called using a track map first you
have to track your footage that's number
one after that I'll just make a solid
with Ctrl y parent it to the track null
and before we draw a mask make sure the
solid completely covers the area you're
trying a roto that way we only have to
do this once and I'll draw that mask
zoom on in get up between them leaves
we're only doing this once so do it
right yeah then we duplicate our footage
and reference the solid as the track
matte from that footage all right and
assuming your track is solid you're
locked in and if your track shifts a bit
you only need to make one or two
keyframes as opposed to one per frame I
use this same method to Roto out all
these foreground objects for this Tokyo
Tower shot but instead of a 2d tracking
method I use the after effects camera
tracker to generate solids in 3D space
since each of these elements move at
different speeds because of their
position and Z space and finally I'll
hit you guys with this last one before
we call it and that is removing objects
from your footage all right because we
don't want the original peeking out from
behind our Lego version you know so I'm
actually just going to use content aware
fill in After Effects I'll utilize the
track matte method to Roto out my
subject and with the footage selected
I'll go to window content aware fill
it's very simple and easy to use you
have three methods of removal to choose
from an object works best for this kind
of setup so I'll just run with default
settings and see what we get it takes a
minute or so but hey if your results
look like but you know it might be
beneficial to generate a reference frame
where you can manually build one out in
Photoshop by going to edit content aware
fill and manually selecting the parts of
the image Photoshop references to fill
in the blank pixels it'll look nicer
than if you just sampled the whole image
and sometimes it's best to paint this
out in chunks for the best results
once you save the Photoshop file and run
the fill in After Effects it'll crunch
you out a filled in background using
your reference frame now this isn't
perfect but it's perfect for what we're
using it for this workflow is great for
any 3D to 2D process because once we get
to this point iterations are as easy as
adding more surface imperfections
punching up the lights maybe even
updating the old model with a new one
from Paul and rendering a V2 that will
auto update in After Effects with a
simple alt drag if you guys want to
double down on this workflow I have two
longer videos covering this process in
Cinema 4D and after effects utilizing
different camera tracking techniques
modeling texturing and lighting The
Works everything if you learn something
new with this video let me know in the
comment section below I'm curious to
know what it is and actually more
importantly what you didn't learn if
there's something I didn't cover if I
didn't cover correctly let me know down
below and we'll chat it out but hey
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with me and allowing yourself to time to
learn and grow together it's been chill
I will be hard at work on the short film
with Paul so subscribe to catch it when
it drops hit up Paul's channel in the
description for more Lego bills and I
will see you guys next Saturday July
29th for the reveal of the new 3D
Community challenge buckle up for it
y'all
it's gonna be big I'll see you guys soon
peace
[Music]